lo que vamos a tratar en este vídeo es
el teorema del valor intermedio que a
pesar de estos términos matemáticos que
verán justo ahorita quiero pensar que es
uno de los teoremas más intuitivos que
hay posiblemente el teorema más
intuitivo con el que te encontrarás en
gran parte de tu carrera matemática así
que primero lo voy a leer y después lo
voy a interpretar y con esto yo espero
que tú puedas ver que es bastante obvio
no voy a probarlo en este vídeo pero
creo que aquí en el fundamento
conceptual debería de ser bastante
sencillo entonces el teorema nos dicen
supón que f
es una función continua para cada punto
en el intervalo
avn y observa que estamos en un
intervalo cerrado
incluimos a e incluimos a ver así que
permítanme dibujar un par de ejemplos de
cómo se podría ver esta función
dada esta oración es decir estamos
suponiendo que f es una función continua
para cada punto en el intervalo
así que si por aquí tengo a mi hijo
james y por acá me tomó a mi eje x
déjame ponerles nombre este va a ser mi
eje y este va a ser mi eje x y ahora me
voy a tomar una respectiva am supongamos
que este es mi valor de amd y una
respectiva ven supongamos que este es mi
valor de b
efe es una función continua para cada
punto en el intervalo
eso significa que con seguridad tiene
que estar definido en cada punto entre a
y b porque para hacer una función
continua debe estar definida en cada
punto y además el límite de la función a
medida que nos aproximamos a ese punto
debe de ser igual al valor de la función
en ese punto así que la función en
definitiva va a tener una f
supongamos que por aquí me tomo a efe am
déjame ponerla
este va a ser mi valor efe de am y en
definitiva también voy a tener una fp si
por aquí me tomo a efe supongamos por
aquí podría ser al revés podría ser que
fuera más pequeño que fedea de hecho
ahorita voy a hacer un caso parecido
pero bueno en este primer caso voy a
suponer que f es más grande que fedea
aquí lo voy a poner
efe db pero si tratan de imaginar una
función continua una manera de pensarlo
es la siguiente si somos continuos sobre
este intervalo que tengo aquí entonces
tomamos el valor de la función en un
punto de este intervalo aquí en fedea y
si somos continuos debemos de ser
capaces de llegar al otro punto a este
punto aquí sin levantar nuestro lápiz
así que puedo hacer un montón de cosas
mientras estemos recordando que vamos a
hacer la gráfica de una función es decir
no podría yo hacer algo como esto porque
esto
es una función pero como si tenemos una
función continua entonces podría dibujar
algo como esto esta es una función
continua y observa que no levante mi
lápiz en ningún momento al dibujar esta
función es decir que si de alguna manera
tengo que levantar mi lápiz supongamos
que estoy dibujando mi función y de
repente levanto mi lápiz y sigo por acá
en definitiva esto no es una función
continua
otro ejemplo si voy dibujando mi función
y de repente levanto el lápiz me voy por
acá y sigo con mi función ops en
definitiva no es una función continua y
en definitiva tampoco tengo una función
continua si works me voy para acá y
después regresó por acá y termina aquí
esta no es una función continua observa
que despegue mi lápiz así que esta
tampoco es una función continua y me voy
a quedar con esta este es un buen
ejemplo de una función continua pero
también puedo dibujar a otro tipo de
función continua y de hecho lo voy a
hacer voy a hacer otro ejemplo vamos a
dibujar por aquí
y vamos a dibujar por aquí
y bueno déjame ponerles sus nombres este
va a ser mi eje bien y por aquí tengo mi
eje x y se me ocurre que ahora podemos
tomar
a negativa podría tener por aquí a am
puede ser positivo negativa y lo mismo
para ver que puede ser positivo o puede
ser negativo no importa pero en esta
ocasión vamos a voltear las cosas nos
voy a decir que f
es más grande lo voy a tener como un por
acan efe fm lo voy a tomar por aquí así
que déjame poner que este es f de am y
por acá tengo am
efe dv efe db y de nuevo vamos a dibujar
una función continua entre estos dos
puntos
efe de am y fm así que voy a dibujar una
función sin levantar mi lápiz y voy a
suponer que tengo la gráfica de una
función que se ve más o menos así así
que estos son sólo dos ejemplos de una
infinidad de casos donde podría tener
una
continuamos para cada punto en el
intervalo
en ese intervalo cerrado ahora dada esta
primera frase hay dos formas de plantear
la conclusión el teorema del valor
intermedio nos dice lo siguiente dado
esto la conclusión se puede escribir de
alguna de estas dos formas por eso
incluye ambas la primera forma de
decirlo es que efecto mar a cada valor
/ efe de am y fm en ese intervalo o
puede ser algo similar observa si me
fijo aquí
/ efe de am y fm observa que mi función
va a tomar cada uno de estos valores en
este intervalo por ejemplo si llamo a
este valor l
entonces observa que existe un valor
aquí donde se toman esta l pasa lo mismo
por acá si me fijo en todos los valores
/ efe de am y fm todos los valores
no se me toma algún valor arbitrario se
me ocurre tomarme este dakar observa que
esta l se toman aquí y también se toma
aquí y también se toma aquí pero toman
al menos un valor en todo este intervalo
entonces eso es lo que nos dice la
primera forma de escribir la conclusión
pero también hay otra forma de escribir
la conclusión la misma conclusión que es
esta es una forma tal vez un poco más
matemática dicen para cualquier l
/ efe fbi existe un valor sem en este
intervalo cerrado a como ven tal que fcc
es igual a l
entonces al menos existe una sem en este
caso esta sería nuestro valor de s
aquí estamos tomando c pero en este caso
tenemos varios candidatos por ejemplo
este sería un candidato para este valor
de cm aquí tenemos otro candidato para
este valor de cm y por acá tenemos un
tercer candidato para este valor desea
entonces para cualquier el m
/ efe de am y fm existen y aquí debería
decir al menos un valor entonces aquí
voy a poner que aquí debería decir al
menos
- un valor sem en este intervalo cerrado
como ven tal que fcc mc a igual a l
justo como estamos viendo en estas dos
gráficas ahora tengo es algo divertido
que te podría entretener durante unos
minutos es tratar de dibujar una función
donde esta primera conclusión sea verdad
pero de alguna manera la segunda
conclusión no sea verdad entonces dirían
bien vamos a tratar de suponer que hay
una l donde no hay una c en ese
intervalo y tal vez te quede más claro
si lo dibujo así que para eso voy a
mover la pantalla y vamos a tratar de
dibujar aquí lo que estoy diciendo por
aquí me voy a tomar de nuevo a mis ejes
voy a tener por aquí a mi rey y por aquí
me voy a tomar a mi eje x ok vamos a
ponerles nombre este es mi eje i
por aquí me voy a tomar mi eje x y para
que sea más sencillo voy a decir que
este es mi valor de amd ambos van a ser
positivos este es mi valor de b y bueno
voy a decir que por aquí no tengo a efe
de este por aquí es mi valor de f de am
ok y por aquí me voy a tomar
efe dv voy a suponer que por aquí tengo
a efe debe dejar de ponerle su nombre
esté aquí es fpv y ahora voy a dibujar a
mi función continua y como es continua
entonces tenemos que ser capaces de
dibujar una función desde este punto
hasta este otro punto sin despegar el
lápiz desde este punto y coma efe de am
hasta este punto
efe de viena vamos a suponer que no se
existe una l por aquí esta va a ser mi l
ok y voy a suponer que nunca tomamos
este
esta función continua nunca toma este
valor
/ efe efe db entonces nunca vamos a
tomar este valor crees que eso sea
posible
bien pues vamos a ver si puedo dibujar
eso me voy a tomar una función recuerda
no voy a despegar el lápiz así que me
voy acercando y no la quiero tocar me
pude acercando más y me puedo ir
acercando más pero en definitiva no hay
forma tengo que cruzar esta línea
punteada si no quiero levantar mi lápiz
en realidad tenemos que cruzar esta
recta y por lo tanto estoy encontrando
un valor sem en este caso este sería mi
valor de ese donde tomamos el valor de l
al aplicar la función y esta se observa
que cae en este intervalo cerrado una
vez más aquí no les estoy dando la
prueba pero yo espero que tengas una
mejor intuición de lo que está pasando
con el teorema del valor intermedio y la
clave aquí es recordar que estamos
trabajando con una función
si hacen su gráfica y tenemos que
dibujarla desde el punto
efe hasta el punto b efe db sin despegar
el lápiz entonces tenemos una función
continua y por lo tanto vamos a tomar
cada valor
/ efe de am y fm